Government in this country, you may have heard, is not running so smoothly these days. That was true in the United States Capitol this week if you were a senator wanting to do the official count of electoral college votes, having your work delayed by an angry mob. That was true if you were a dentist in New York City, hoping to get a COVID vaccine from your state government.
正如你可能听说过的那样，这个国家的政府最近运转得不那么顺利。如果你是一位想要正式统计选举人团投票的参议员，而你的工作被一群暴民耽误了，那么本周在美国国会大厦确实如此。如果你是一位在纽约市希望从州政府那里获得新冠疫苗的牙医，情况也确实如此。
Dentists are supposed to be in group 1A, according to the Centers for Disease Control guidelines. They were supposed to be in the very first group to get the vaccine, because peering closely into people's open mouths all day puts them in danger of a virus that is carried by droplets on people's breath. But when they started rolling out the vaccine in December in New York, not only did dentists not get vaccinated--
根据疾病控制与预防中心的指导方针，牙医应该属于1A类群体。他们本应是第一批接种疫苗的人，因为整天近距离观察人们张开的嘴巴，使他们面临接触人们呼吸中飞沫所携带病毒的危险。但当纽约在12月开始推广疫苗时，牙医们不仅没有接种疫苗——
We were just kept in the dark.
我们只是被蒙在鼓里。
Alisa Neymark's a New York dentist. She says she and other dentists did get emails from their state dental association.
阿丽莎·内马克（Alisa Neymark）是一位纽约牙医。她说她和其他牙医确实收到了来自州牙科协会的电子邮件。
I can send you some of the emails that they've sent to me. And they're just very confusing.
我可以发给你一些他们发给我的邮件。它们真的很令人困惑。
Confusing like how?
怎么个困惑法？
Like they're confused. They say, we know that dentists are in group 1A. We don't yet know when or how you'll be able to make an appointment.
就像他们自己也很困惑一样。他们说，我们知道牙医属于1A类。我们还不知道你们何时或如何能够预约。
For Dr. Neymark, at one level-- and I don't want to overstate this. She seems like a careful, measured kind of person, who does not get up on a soapbox. At one level, to her, it is not surprising that dentists would get this kind of treatment. Dentists, she says, they don't get respect.
对于内马克医生来说，在某种层面上——我不想夸大其词。她看起来是一个谨慎、有分寸的人，不会轻易发表长篇大论。在某种层面上，对她来说，牙医会受到这种对待并不令人惊讶。她说，牙医得不到尊重。
There is a bias against dentists. There is definitely-- there's a cultural kind of fear. I'm just thinking about that-- what's the movie--
对牙医存在偏见。肯定存在一种文化上的恐惧。我只是在想那个——那部电影叫什么来着——
I thought she was going to say Marathon Man, but no.
我以为她要说《马拉松人》（Marathon Man），但并没有。
--where they go to Las Vegas?
——他们去拉斯维加斯的那部电影？
The Hangover. She meant The Hangover, where Ed Helms plays a dentist.
《宿醉》（The Hangover）。她说的是《宿醉》，艾德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）在里面扮演一名牙医。
And he's a dentist. And he gets made fun of for being a dentist, right? It's like this big joke that we have. Oh, you're not a doctor. You're a dentist.
他是一名牙医。他因为是牙医而被人嘲笑，对吧？这就像我们开的一个大玩笑。哦，你又不是医生。你是个牙医。
So not even being told when they'd get the vaccine, even though they're 1A, she said par for the course. She and other New York dentists did get an official email on New Year's Eve, an email that had been sent out at the very businesslike time of 5:07 PM, New Year's Eve, that did have a promising link to vaccination locations. But when Dr. Neymark clicked on that link with her information, she found there's nothing for dentists in New York City.
所以，即使他们属于1A类，却连何时能接种疫苗都没被告知，她说这再正常不过了。她和其他纽约牙医确实在除夕夜收到了一封正式邮件，这封邮件是在除夕夜下午5:07这个非常正式的时间发出的，其中确实包含了一个通往疫苗接种地点的很有希望的链接。但当内马克医生用她的信息点击该链接时，她发现纽约市没有任何针对牙医的内容。
It isn't just that they seem to be at the back of the line. It's the lack of information. That's what gets to Dr. Neymark. She finally did learn when the state would be vaccinating dentists, but it wasn't from any official source. Somebody she knew just texted her. The vaccinations were supposedly going to start this week, the week that began Monday, January 4th, the fourth week of the vaccine rollout. But when she tried to actually schedule an appointment for a shot on the official website, there seemed to be no available appointments for dentists.
这不仅仅是他们似乎被排在队伍的最后。而是缺乏信息。这就是让内马克医生感到困扰的地方。她最终确实了解了州政府何时会为牙医接种疫苗，但并不是从任何官方渠道得知的。她认识的一个人只是发短信告诉了她。疫苗接种本应从本周开始，即1月4日星期一开始的那一周，这是疫苗推广的第四周。但当她试图在官方网站上为接种疫苗预约时，似乎没有任何可供牙医预约的名额。
But people have been checking, and so, we've been emailing each other. So it's kind of this underground network, people who are kind of looking out for each other. Oh, I know that you haven't been vaccinated yet. I just got an appointment. Let me text you.
但大家一直在查看，所以我们一直在互相发送电子邮件。所以这就像是一个地下网络，人们互相照顾。哦，我知道你还没接种疫苗。我刚预约到了。让我给你发个短信。
So, basically, it's this underground thing, like it's a Russia under Stalin or something. And you guys are passing each other little pieces of paper, saying, here's where you go for your shot.
所以，基本上，这是一个地下组织，就像斯大林统治下的俄罗斯什么的。你们在互相传递小纸条，说，去这里打针。
Exactly, it's like, the bread line is over there.
没错，就像说，领面包的队伍在那边。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Go ahead and sign up. I was actually born in the Soviet Union, so. [LAUGHS]
去报名吧。我其实出生在苏联，所以。[笑声]
Oh, you were?
哦，你是吗？
I was, yeah.
是的，我是。
So you have training. You're ready.
所以你有这方面的训练。你准备好了。
Yeah, I'm ready.
是的，我准备好了。
I talked to somebody on the New York State Vaccine Distribution Task Force, which is supposed to be advising the state on how to do all this. Her name's Rose Duhan. She also runs the Community Healthcare Association of New York State, where she says she is spending all day, every day, trying to distribute vaccine. I have to say, she made a pretty convincing case for why dentists are not being vaccinated till week four, even though they're designated 1A.
我和纽约州疫苗分配特别工作组的一位成员谈过，该工作组负责就如何执行所有这些事宜向州政府提供建议。她的名字叫罗斯·杜汉（Rose Duhan）。她还管理着纽约州社区医疗保健协会，她说她每天整天都在努力分发疫苗。我不得不说，她提出了一个非常有说服力的理由，解释了为什么牙医直到第四周才被接种疫苗，尽管他们被指定为1A类。
In New York state, the state estimated that there are two million healthcare workers, two million people who fall into that 1A priority. So that's a lot of people. And it's just not feasible to vaccinate everybody the first day.
在纽约州，州政府估计有两百万医护人员，两百万人属于1A优先级别。所以那是很多人。第一天就给所有人接种疫苗是不现实的。
So the state decided the first dibs should go to people who are in more immediate danger, like medical personnel who care directly for COVID patients and nursing home staffs and residents. When I ran that by Dr. Neymark, she agreed it seemed sensible. But nobody had told this to her.
因此，州政府决定应优先考虑那些处于更直接危险中的人，例如直接照顾新冠患者的医务人员以及疗养院的工作人员和居民。当我把这些告诉内马克医生时，她也同意这看起来是明智的。但没人告诉过她这些。
Nobody is pretending vaccine distribution is going well in New York right now. The state has only managed to administer about 40% of the vaccine that it's been given, which is actually better than the country as a whole, which has used about a fourth of the vaccine that's out there. But still, the phrase that Rose Duhan used to describe her own feeling about how it's going was this.
没有人假装目前的纽约疫苗分发进展顺利。该州仅成功施用了所获得疫苗的约40%，这实际上比整个国家要好，美国已经使用了现有疫苗的约四分之一。但即便如此，罗斯·杜汉形容自己对进展情况的感受时用了这个短语。
Somewhat panicked. [LAUGHS]
有点恐慌。[笑声]
She ticked off some of the many, many logistical challenges they faced-- figuring out which facilities could deliver the most shots and how to staff and schedule and track hundreds of thousands of people getting vaccine.
她列举了他们面临的许多许多后勤挑战——弄清楚哪些设施能提供最多的注射，以及如何为数十万接种疫苗的人员配备人员、安排日程和进行追踪。
They had to create scheduling software to figure out what to do in smaller health centers if people don't show up for appointments, which is an issue because once you have opened up a vial of the vaccine, you have to use all the 10 doses inside of it in a few hours, or they go bad. There are health centers who have been told to vaccinate people from other kinds of facilities, like mental health providers.
他们不得不创建调度软件，以弄清楚如果人们没有按时赴约，在较小的医疗中心该怎么办，这是一个问题，因为一旦你打开了一小瓶疫苗，你必须在几个小时内用完里面的10剂，否则它们就会变质。有些医疗中心被告知要为来自其他类型设施的人接种疫苗，比如心理健康服务提供者。
And the health centers are trying to figure out, OK, how much allocation do they have, how much of the other provider's staff can they accommodate, how can they get those people either to come to the health center, or is there a way to get some of the vaccine to those residential settings.
医疗中心正在努力弄清楚，好吧，他们有多少分配量，他们能容纳多少其他提供者的员工，他们如何让这些人来到医疗中心，或者有没有办法将部分疫苗送到那些住宿设施。
Oy. It's so-- I don't know. The details are so kind of mind numbing when you describe it.
哎呀。这真是……我不知道。当你描述它的时候，细节真是让人麻木。
Yes.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yes.
是的。
I love that this process begins on the front end with these super geniuses using this incredibly advanced science to invent the thing. That was the hard part. And then, just literally, like, how do we schedule people from this facility into a time when we can get enough of them to use all the dose in the vial? That's where we're getting stuck.
我喜欢这个过程在前端开始的方式，超级天才们使用极其先进的科学来发明这种东西。那是困难的部分。然后，字面意思上，就像，我们如何安排来自这个设施的人，在一个我们可以让他们中有足够多的人来使用小瓶中所有剂量的时间段内？这就是我们被困住的地方。
Yes, and I think that's really where the people who do that kind of thing don't get enough credit. Exactly.
是的，我认为这确实是那些做这类工作的人没有得到足够赞誉的地方。完全正确。
There's no Nobel Prize for that.
这没有诺贝尔奖。
Right.
对。
There's no Nobel Prize for scheduling people.
调度人员没有诺贝尔奖。
One person who finally did get scheduled-- Dr. Neymark. Though the only appointment that a dentist like her could get was 40 miles away. The situation we're in now is that the CDC made a carefully thought out plan for who should get immunized first and second and third. And then, that plan collided with reality. And when and where we'll all get our vaccine is going to depend on these logistical details and how well they are managed.
有一位最终成功预约的人——内马克医生。尽管像她这样的牙医唯一能预约到的地方是在40英里外。我们现在所处的局面是，疾控中心制定了一个经过深思熟虑的计划，规定了谁应该第一、第二、第三接种。然后，那个计划与现实发生了碰撞。我们所有人何时何地能接种疫苗，将取决于这些后勤细节以及它们的管理水平。
Today on our program, we see just how common this is. We have other stories of this happening-- scarce resources that need to go to somebody and how they end up getting allocated, whether those resources are a place to stay for the night, or love and companionship being redistributed in all kinds of new ways since the pandemic. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们看看这种情况有多普遍。我们还有其他类似的故事——稀缺资源需要分配给某人，以及它们最终是如何被分配的，无论这些资源是过夜的地方，还是自疫情以来以各种新方式重新分配的爱与陪伴。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, God Committee. So we start with this example of a very pure situation of people who have been given the difficult task of trying to figure out how to distribute something important-- in fact, in this case, life-saving medicine. They're deciding basically who will live or die, and the very idealistic solution they came up with. Lilly Sullivan tells the story, which starts, as you might expect, with a medical breakthrough.
第一幕，上帝委员会。我们从一个非常纯粹的情况开始，人们被赋予了艰巨的任务，试图弄清楚如何分配重要的东西——事实上，在这个案例中，是救命药。他们基本上是在决定谁生谁死，以及他们想出的非常理想化的解决方案。莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）讲述了这个故事，故事的开始，正如你所预料的那样，是一项医学突破。
Back in 1960, a doctor named Belding Scribner had a patient-- a young man with kidney problems. It was something Dr. Scribner had no way to treat, so he had to send the guy home to his family to die. The case haunted Dr. Scribner.
早在1960年，一位名叫贝尔丁·斯克里布纳（Belding Scribner）的医生有一位病人——一名患有肾脏疾病的年轻人。这是斯克里布纳医生无法治疗的疾病，所以他不得不把那个人送回家等死。这个病例一直困扰着斯克里布纳医生。
One night, he woke up at 4:00 AM with an idea, a way he could have saved that man-- a Teflon tube that could be stitched into the blood vessels of the arm and stay implanted there. It made long-term dialysis possible for the first time. They'd pull the blood out of someone's body, clean it the way a kidney does, and put it back in. People called it a medical miracle, an artificial organ that could cheat death.
一天晚上，他在凌晨4点醒来时想到了一个主意，一个他本可以挽救那个人的方法——一根特氟龙管，可以缝合在手臂的血管里并植入在那里。这使长期透析首次成为可能。他们会把血从人的身体里抽出来，像肾脏一样清洗它，然后再放回去。人们称之为医学奇迹，一种可以欺骗死亡的人造器官。
There was a problem, though. The machine they came up with was big and complicated. They built it from a Sears Roebuck freezer that they'd modified with a bunch of other parts. Nurses called the machine "the monster" because it was so big and unwieldy. And every patient needed to spend dozens of hours each week connected to it. And only five of these machines existed. This was still in the experimental stages, so they could only take care of a few people. And there were thousands of people dying from kidney failure every year in the country.
不过有一个问题。他们制造的机器又大又复杂。他们用一台西尔斯百货（Sears Roebuck）的冰柜改装，并加入了许多其他零件。护士们称这台机器为“怪物”，因为它太庞大且难以操作。每个病人每周都需要花几十个小时连接在它上面。而这种机器当时只有五台。这仍处于实验阶段，所以他们只能照顾几个人。而全国每年有成千上万的人死于肾衰竭。
So, on one hand, a miracle. On the other, Dr. Scribner had traded one harrowing problem, a medical one, for an equally harrowing ethical problem. How do you choose which few to save and which thousands would die? Dr. Scribner started getting flooded with requests from people desperate to be put on the machine. The pressure was crushing him. Saying no was ensuring a person's death. He went to the administrators who were helping to oversee this whole project and asked for help. The administrators took it from there.
所以，一方面，这是一个奇迹。另一方面，斯克里布纳医生用一个令人揪心的医学问题，换取了一个同样令人揪心的伦理问题。你怎么选择救哪几个，而让哪几千人死去？斯克里布纳医生开始被那些渴望被安置在机器上的人的请求所淹没。压力快要压垮他了。拒绝就等于确保了一个人的死亡。他去找了协助监督整个项目的管理人员寻求帮助。管理人员接手了这件事。
The first thing the administrators decided is, you know what? This isn't a medical decision at all. This is a societal decision. So they decided to assemble a group of people. They chose these people not because these people had any medical knowledge-- or, really, any relevant experience at all. These were ordinary people, hand-picked to represent a cross-section of moral American society.
管理人员决定的第一件事是，你知道吗？这根本不是一个医学决定。这是一个社会决定。所以他们决定召集一群人。他们选择这些人并不是因为这些人有任何医学知识——或者，真的，有任何相关的经验。这些人是普通人，是精挑细选出来代表美国道德社会横截面的人。
I am a banker.
我是一名银行家。
I am a surgeon.
我是一名外科医生。
I am a lawyer.
我是一名律师。
This is from a documentary from 1965.
这是1965年一部纪录片里的内容。
I am a labor leader.
我是一名工会领袖。
I'm a housewife.
我是一名家庭主妇。
I am a clergyman.
我是一名牧师。
The names, the faces of those who serve on this committee are never made known to those who apply for the places on the kidney machine.
在这个委员会服务的人的名字和面孔，永远不会向那些申请使用肾透析机名额的人公开。
The committee was strict about anonymity. In the documentary, their heads are darkened so you can't see their faces. These people had just been going about their lives when the dialysis center's administrators asked them to come in. One of the people in the group, a young minister, told them it wasn't for him to choose who would live and die.
委员会对匿名性要求非常严格。在纪录片中，他们的头部被遮黑，你看不到他们的脸。这些人当时只是在过自己的生活，直到透析中心的管理人员请求他们过来。小组中的一个人，一位年轻的牧师，告诉他们，决定谁生谁死不是他该做的事。
The doctor said, "We are not asking you to decide who will die. This is already determined. We are asking you to help decide who will be given the opportunity of extended life." The minister agreed to do it. They all did. A few of them said it would be too cruel to force this responsibility onto someone else. Officially, they were called the Admissions and Policies Committee of the Seattle Artificial Kidney Center at Swedish Hospital. But a lot of people called them the God Committee.
医生说：“我们不是让你决定谁该死。这已经决定了。我们是请你帮助决定谁将获得延长生命的机会。”牧师同意了。他们都同意了。其中几个人说，把这种责任强加给别人太残忍了。官方称他们为瑞典医院西雅图人工肾中心入院与政策委员会。但很多人称他们为“上帝委员会”。
At the time-- again, this is in 1960-- there was no blueprint for this. The doctors gave them no guidelines. The committee considered first come, first served, or drawing straws. But they'd been told to use their consciences. So they came up with a set of principles and rules.
当时——再次强调，这是1960年——没有先例。医生没有给他们任何指导方针。委员会考虑过先到先得，或者抽签。但他们被告知要凭借良心行事。所以他们制定了一套原则和规则。
The first rules were clear-cut. The treatment was in Seattle, so they'd only look at applicants who lived in Washington state. Washington taxpayers were funding the research. They also decided no one over 45. There could be medical complications. And those people had at least had a shot at life. And no one under 18. The treatment was physically and emotionally demanding. No one knew how it might affect kids.
第一条规则很明确。治疗地点在西雅图，所以他们只看居住在华盛顿州的申请者。华盛顿州的纳税人资助了这项研究。他们还决定不接受45岁以上的人。可能会有并发症。而且那些人至少已经有过一次生命机会了。也不接受18岁以下的人。这种治疗在身体和情感上要求都很高。没人知道它会如何影响孩子。
But those rules only got them so far. They decided they'd base their final selection on something else-- social worth. They'd try to save the person whose death would most hurt society. They made a list of the factors they'd weigh-- marital status, number of dependents, income, net worth-- to pay for the treatment-- sex, education, occupation, emotional stability, past performance, future potential, and personal references.
但这些规则只能帮他们到这里。他们决定将最终选择建立在其他基础上——社会价值。他们会试图拯救那些死亡会对社会造成最大伤害的人。他们列出了一系列要权衡的因素——婚姻状况、受抚养人人数、收入、净资产（以支付治疗费用）、性别、教育、职业、情感稳定性、过往表现、未来潜力以及个人推荐。
They made a policy of never meeting any of the candidates in person or even knowing their names because denying a person you'd met face-to-face seemed too hard. They once let a journalist come see how they made one of these decisions. They just had a meeting where the doctors had presented them with five applications, and the committee could only pick two. They walked the journalists through how they made that choice, tried to recreate for her the conversation they'd just had. Here's a transcript of their discussion.
他们制定了一项政策，绝不亲自见任何候选人，甚至不打听他们的名字，因为拒绝一个你面对面见过的人似乎太难了。他们曾经让一名记者来看他们是如何做出这些决定的。他们只是开了一个会，医生向他们提供了五份申请，而委员会只能挑选两个。他们向记者介绍了他们如何做出选择的过程，试图为她重现他们刚才进行的对话。这是他们讨论的文字记录。
Banker-- "Just to get the ball rolling, why don't we start with number one-- the housewife from Walla Walla?" Surgeon-- "This patient could not commute for the treatment from Walla Walla, so she would have to find a way to move her family to Seattle." Banker-- "Exactly my point. It says here that her husband has no funds to make such a move."
银行家——“为了抛砖引玉，为什么我们不先从第一个开始——那个瓦拉瓦拉的家庭主妇？”外科医生——“这位病人无法从瓦拉瓦拉通勤进行治疗，所以她必须想办法把家人搬到西雅图。”银行家——“这正是我的重点。这里说她丈夫没有资金进行这种搬迁。”
Lawyer-- "Then are you proposing we eliminate this candidate on the grounds that she could not possibly accept treatment if it were offered?" Minister-- "How can we compare a family situation of two children, such as this woman in Walla Walla, with a family of six children, such as patient number four, the aircraft worker?"
律师——“那么你是否建议我们以她如果获得治疗也不可能接受为由淘汰这个候选人？”牧师——“我们怎么能比较一个有两个孩子的家庭状况，比如瓦拉瓦拉的这位女士，和一个有六个孩子的家庭，比如4号病人，那个飞机制造工人呢？”
This is something they talk about a lot. If one candidate has one kid and the other has two, should you pick the candidate with two kids? They go round and round, trying to answer a question that has no answer.
这是他们经常讨论的问题。如果一个候选人有一个孩子，另一个有两个，你应该选有两个孩子的那个吗？他们反反复复，试图回答一个没有答案的问题。
Labor leader-- "For the children's sake, we've got to reckon with the surviving parent's opportunity to remarry. And a woman with three children has a better chance to find a new husband than a very young widow with six children." Surgeon-- "How can we possibly be sure of that? How do the rest of you feel about number three, the small businessman with three children? I'm impressed that his doctor took special pains to mention that this man is active in church work. This is an indication to me of character and moral strength."
工会领袖——“为了孩子们的缘故，我们必须考虑到在世的父母再婚的机会。而一个有三个孩子的女人比一个有六个孩子的年轻寡妇更有机会找到新丈夫。”外科医生——“我们怎么可能确定这一点？你们其他人对三号，那个有三个孩子的小商人感觉如何？我印象深刻的是他的医生特别费心提到这个人在教会工作中很活跃。这对我来说是品格和道德力量的标志。”
Housewife-- "Which would certainly help him conform to the demands of the treatment." Lawyer-- "It would also help him to endure a lingering death." Housewife-- "If we're still looking for the men with the highest potential of service to society, I think we must consider that the chemists and the accountant have the finest educational backgrounds of all five candidates."
家庭主妇——“这肯定会帮助他适应治疗的要求。”律师——“这也将帮助他忍受缓慢的死亡。”家庭主妇——“如果我们仍在寻找最有潜力为社会服务的人，我认为我们必须考虑化学家和会计师拥有所有五位候选人中最好的教育背景。”
In the end, the people they chose were mostly men, white, and well-off-- people like them. Which seems inevitable, given the criteria they'd come up with to select for what they called social worth-- education, future potential, income. The treatment cost about $15,000 a year, what would be about $130,000 today, and it often wasn't covered by insurance. They'd written all these rules to try to be fair, but they'd created an outcome that was anything but. Sometimes, when you try to guess your own biases, you come up with a very incomplete list.
最终，他们选择的人大多是男性、白人且富有——像他们一样的人。考虑到他们为筛选所谓的社会价值而制定的标准——教育、未来潜力、收入，这似乎是不可避免的。治疗费用约为每年1.5万美元，相当于今天的约13万美元，而且通常不被保险覆盖。他们写下所有这些规则是为了尝试公平，但他们创造的结果却远非如此。有时，当你试图猜测自己的偏见时，你会得出一份非常不完整的清单。
In a letter the minister wrote a few years later, he talked about how he'd been extra careful to guard against his own biases and not favor people who were good church members. But later on, he worried that he might have gone too far, been unfairly hard on religious people. The final votes were always made by consensus. They said that gave them some comfort.
在牧师几年后写的一封信中，他谈到了他是如何格外小心地防范自己的偏见，而不是偏袒那些优秀的教会成员的。但后来，他担心自己可能做得太过分了，对宗教人士过于苛刻了。最终的投票总是通过共识做出的。他们说这给他们带来了一些安慰。
--some differences. I think that we are all of the same opinion at the present time. Does everyone agree?
——有些分歧。我认为我们目前意见一致。大家都同意吗？
Agree.
同意。
Well, I think having arrived at that point, that we are then ready to cast a vote in our poll. All in favor of accepting Mr. D, say aye.
好吧，我想既然到了那一点，我们就准备好在民意调查中投票了。所有赞成接受D先生的人，请说“同意”。
Aye.
同意。
And opposed? Mr. D is accepted as the next candidate for our kidney center.
有反对的吗？D先生被接受为我们肾中心的下一位候选人。
It's hard to find many recordings of Dr. Scribner. But I found an oral history recorded decades after all this happened, where he talked about the God Committee.
很难找到斯克里布纳医生的许多录音。但我发现了一份在这之后几十年记录的口述历史，他在其中谈到了上帝委员会。
This was widely criticized afterward.
这事后受到了广泛批评。
The problem, just in a word, was you were faced with more people.
总之，问题就是你面对的人太多了。
Impossible choices. All right. Of course it wasn't fair at all, but it was the best we could do, and--
不可能的选择。好吧。当然，它一点也不公平，但这是我们能做的最好的了，而且——
Dr. Scribner, he talked to these patients constantly. He couldn't have the distance that the God Committee had. I've talked to a few of his patients. They all said he was a really caring doctor. And there was one patient he particularly liked, a patient whose experience ended up changing everything for dialysis and for the God Committee. She was a teenage girl named Caroline. I talked to her mom, Susan.
斯克里布纳医生，他不断地与这些病人交谈。他不可能保持上帝委员会所拥有的那种距离。我和他的几位病人谈过。他们都说他是一位非常关怀的医生。他特别喜欢其中一位病人，一位其经历最终改变了透析和上帝委员会一切的病人。她是一个名叫卡罗琳的十几岁女孩。我和她妈妈苏珊谈过。
She had a sunny personality. She was a very happy, happy, happy girl, a very likable one. Well-rounded, I would like to say.
她性格开朗。她是一个非常快乐、快乐、快乐的女孩，一个非常讨人喜欢的女孩。全面发展，我想这么说。
How did you know that Dr. Scribner liked Caroline so much?
你怎么知道斯克里布纳医生那么喜欢卡罗琳？
It's sort of instinctive. As a mother, you get the feeling for if somebody likes your kid or not.
这是一种直觉。作为一个母亲，你会有感觉，别人是否喜欢你的孩子。
Caroline was 15, a good student, scout leader, taught piano. When she was sick, the athletes would carry her up and down the stairs at school. Kids from her youth group at church would donate blood. When Caroline's kidneys started to fail, Dr. Scribner submitted her case to the committee, even though he knew the rule-- no one under 18.
卡罗琳15岁，是个好学生，童子军领袖，教钢琴。当她生病时，运动员们会背着她上下学校的楼梯。她教会青年团的孩子们会为她献血。当卡罗琳的肾脏开始衰竭时，斯克里布纳医生把她的病例提交给了委员会，尽管他知道那条规则——不接受18岁以下的人。
Did he tell you when he put Caroline in front of the committee? Did you know that it was going on?
当他把卡罗琳的情况提交给委员会时，他告诉你了吗？你知道发生了什么吗？
Did I know what was going on? No. No, I didn't know until after the fact that that's what he had done.
我知道发生了什么吗？不。不，直到事后我才知道他做了什么。
Oh.
哦。
Mm-mm. I didn't know there was a committee to choose who lives and dies. And she was turned down.
嗯。我不知道有一个委员会来决定谁生谁死。而且她被拒绝了。
What was that like for you?
那对你来说是什么感觉？
I can remember the conversation. I just know I was totally silent-- trying, I guess, to absorb what was being said. I don't know how you would put into words the feeling you have when you're delivered a death sentence like that. A part of you dies. Everything stops. And it still does when I think about it, as a matter of fact.
我记得那个对话。我只记得我完全沉默了——我猜是在试图消化所说的话。我不知道当你被判死刑时，你该用什么词来形容那种感觉。你的一部分死去了。一切都停止了。事实上，当我想到这件事时，依然如此。
Were you ever angry that the committee didn't just--
你是否曾经因为委员会没有——
No.
没有。
Or that she didn't just--
或者因为她没有——
No, not at all.
不，完全没有。
No?
没有？
Not at all.
完全没有。
Really?
真的吗？
I mean, they have their rules and regulations. And where you may have 100 people and can only take two, you pretty much have to stick by the rules.
我是说，他们有他们的规章制度。当你可能有100个人却只能接受两个时，你几乎必须遵守规则。
Dr. Scribner didn't see it that way.
斯克里布纳医生不这么看。
Dr. Scribner was not content with that decision. He thought he had a good case and had pleaded it well. And I really thought he felt that his cohorts would go along with him. He was a highly respected man. And I don't think he was used to having anybody say no to him.
斯克里布纳医生对那个决定不满意。他认为他有一个很好的理由，而且已经充分辩护了。我真的认为他觉得他的同僚会支持他。他是一位备受尊敬的人。我不认为他习惯于被人拒绝。
Dr. Scribner tried to find a way. He told the committee, "I'll treat her on my own time, nights and weekends. Just let me use the machines." They said no. He couldn't accept it. He had another idea, something he'd been thinking about for a while-- a smaller machine, one that someone could take into their house and run themselves without any medical staff.
斯克里布纳医生试图寻找出路。他告诉委员会：“我会在自己的业余时间治疗她，晚上和周末。就让我用那些机器吧。”他们说不。他无法接受。他有了另一个主意，一个他思考了一段时间的东西——一台更小的机器，一台人们可以带回家自己操作而无需任何医务人员的机器。
It was nowhere near ready to be tested. And that's where we lucked out. And he was going to do whatever it took to keep her around until that machine was ready.
它离测试还差得很远。这就是我们幸运的地方。他打算不惜一切代价让她留下来，直到那台机器准备好。
He called the guy who had helped him build the dialysis machine, an engineer named Albert Babb. He told him about Caroline and said, "Do you think we could make this? She only has four months." Albert asked Dr. Scribner, "Won't the committee get mad that you're going around them?" Dr. Scribner said, "No, this has nothing to do with them. I'll get other funding."
他给那个帮他建造透析机的人打了电话，那是一位名叫阿尔伯特·巴布（Albert Babb）的工程师。他告诉他关于卡罗琳的事，说：“你认为我们能做到吗？她只剩下四个月了。”阿尔伯特问斯克里布纳医生：“委员会不会因为你绕过他们而生气吗？”斯克里布纳医生说：“不会，这与他们无关。我会去寻找其他资金。”
The engineer wanted to help. His whole team did. They weren't technically supposed to. They were at the university, and they were supposed to be working on something else. But they worked nonstop to do it. They decided not to tell the university, concerned that the dean would shut it down. Someone on their team would actually do "dean watch," as they called it, keeping an eye out for the dean and warning their team over the intercom if they saw him.
工程师想帮忙。他的整个团队都想帮忙。他们按规定是不应该帮忙的。他们在大学里，本应在做别的事情。但他们不眠不休地去做。他们决定不告诉大学，担心院长会叫停。他们团队中的某个人甚至会执行所谓的“院长监视”，盯着院长，如果看到他，就通过对讲机警告团队。
In their lab, they put their designs and sketches on sliding panels. When the dean entered the building, they'd quickly switch the panels around to hide their work on the machine. To get around the God Committee, Dr. Scribner set it up independently as a research project. Caroline would use the dialysis machine at home. Susan would run the whole thing.
在实验室里，他们把设计图和草图放在滑动板上。当院长进入大楼时，他们会迅速切换面板，隐藏他们在机器上的工作。为了绕过上帝委员会，斯克里布纳医生独立地将其设置为一个研究项目。卡罗琳将在家中使用透析机。苏珊将负责运行整个过程。
It was presented to us as being a strictly family matter.
这在呈现给我们时被当作纯粹的家庭事务。
To see if a family could run it.
为了看看一个家庭能否操作它。
Correct. I believe it was phrased something like, can layman non-professional people assume the role of engineer and nurse? So, can lay people be trained?
正确。我相信措辞大概是，外行非专业人员能否承担工程师和护士的角色？所以，外行人能受训吗？
The engineers finished the new machine in four months and rushed it to Caroline's house in August of 1964. Susan learned how to do what before had only been done in a hospital-- run the machine that would remove her daughter's blood from her body, wash it, and feed it back in through her arm, except it was happening in the basement of her house in a special room they'd set up for Caroline.
工程师们在四个月内完成了新机器，并于1964年8月将其送到了卡罗琳家。苏珊学会了以前只能在医院做的事情——操作那台能从她女儿身体里抽出血液、清洗并从手臂喂回血液的机器，只不过这是在他们为卡罗琳特别布置的家中地下室进行的。
I would put her on the machine usually between 6 and 7 o'clock at night. And that would mean taking her off after nine or 10 hours. So it was early, early morning, and then she would just stay in bed maybe for an hour and then eat breakfast before she went back to school.
我通常在晚上6点到7点之间把她连上机器。这意味着在9到10个小时后把她摘下来。所以那是凌晨，然后她可能会在床上待一个小时，然后吃早餐，再去学校。
And you'd take her off around 3:00 or 4:00 AM. So you'd wake up in the middle of the night and--
你会在凌晨3点或4点把她摘下来。所以你会在半夜醒来，然后——
Oh, I was awake all night for sure.
哦，我整晚肯定都醒着。
Oh, you would stay awake all night.
哦，你会整晚不睡。
Our machines were so experimental, Lilly. Alarms were going off all the time, and then we'd have to figure out what was wrong with it.
莉莉，我们的机器太具实验性了。警报一直响，然后我们得弄清楚出了什么问题。
A constant problem was that her blood would clot and clog the little tube, the little shunt that Dr. Scribner had invented, in Caroline's arm.
一个持续存在的问题是，她的血液会凝结并堵塞小管子，也就是斯克里布纳医生发明的那根插在卡罗琳手臂上的小分流管。
I would have to get out heparin and saline in a syringe and unblock the clot. If it was unclottable, that was very painful for her. And it hurt me to pain her that way. But I mean, you had to get the blood flowing again, and I had no alternative but to do that. That was probably our biggest hurdle, was just keeping her blood moving.
我不得不拿出注射器里的肝素和生理盐水来清除血块。如果它无法疏通，对她来说非常痛苦。以那种方式让她痛苦，我也很难受。但我意思是，你必须让血液再次流动，我别无选择，只能这样做。那可能是我们最大的障碍，就是保持她的血液流动。
Were you ever worried that you would get something wrong?
你是否曾经担心会出错？
Oh, sure. Sure. Oh, sure. Sure. I mean, when somebody's life is in your hands-- I mean, at least when I felt her life was in my hands, I was always aware that something could go wrong. But I better not let it happen. You have to concentrate. Do everything just right.
哦，当然。当然。哦，当然。当然。我的意思是，当某人的生命掌握在你手中——我是说，至少当我感到她的生命掌握在我手中时，我总是意识到可能会出错。但我最好别让它发生。你必须集中注意力。把每件事都做得恰到好处。
Hm.
嗯。
Because she was sick. And I think my feeling was, oh, I hope she feels better after this, because she was sick.
因为她病了。我想我的感觉是，哦，我希望她在做完之后感觉好点，因为她病了。
And in just a few weeks, Caroline felt better.
仅仅几周后，卡罗琳感觉好多了。
Oh, yeah, she did. Her eyes sparkled, and she was talkative. And I felt like this was the beginning of a new chapter in our life.
哦，是的，她感觉好了。她的眼睛闪闪发光，而且很健谈。我觉得这是我们生活中新篇章的开始。
Yeah. How did Dr. Scribner-- do you know how did he feel when he saw that it was working?
是的。你知道当斯克里布纳医生看到它起作用时他是怎么感觉的吗？
Oh, of course, he was just jubilant. Oh, he was just grinning from ear to ear.
哦，当然，他欣喜若狂。哦，他笑得合不拢嘴。
This research project was supposed to take three years to show whether or not home dialysis could be a viable treatment. But within one year, doctors agreed-- this would work. This is what they would do. Susan kept dialyzing Caroline, and Caroline kept getting better. She graduated high school, started college.
这个研究项目本应花三年时间来展示家庭透析是否可行。但一年内，医生们就达成一致——这行得通。这就是他们要做的事情。苏珊继续给卡罗琳透析，卡罗琳继续好转。她高中毕业，开始了大学生活。
But dialysis is a treatment, not a cure. And it was still experimental. A person's veins and arteries would often scar over and stop accepting the treatment. As the doctors had said, it was a chance at extended life. In Caroline's case, that meant four more years.
但透析是一种治疗，而不是治愈。而且它仍然是实验性的。一个人的静脉和动脉通常会结疤并停止接受治疗。正如医生所说，这是一个延长生命的机会。在卡罗琳的案例中，这意味着又多了四年。
She used up all of her usable veins and arteries. And they were having a very difficult time putting her on dialysis, so that during the time she was in the hospital-- it was two or three weeks, I think. I would dialyze her there as best I could for maybe as little as an hour before the blood quit flowing.
她用尽了所有可用的静脉和动脉。他们非常艰难地给她进行透析，所以在她住院期间——我想大概是两三周。我尽可能地在那里为她透析，可能不到一个小时血液就停止流动了。
Oh.
哦。
And then, she just deteriorated, Lilly.
然后，她就恶化了，莉莉。
Oh, I'm so sorry.
哦，我真遗憾。
She was in intensive care in the hospital. And she died at night when I had gone home. We knew that she wasn't going to come out of it. But so, I guess I was as prepared as anybody could be, knowing that we had done everything we could and that the bottom line is, we'd left a legacy for all the rest of these people-- not only our country, but in the world-- that can live because of what we pioneered.
她在医院重症监护室。在我回家后的那个晚上她去世了。我们知道她挺不过来了。所以我猜，我知道我们已经尽了所能，底线是，我们为其他所有这些人留下了一份遗产——不仅是我们国家的，还有全世界的——他们因为我们首创的东西而能够活下去。
After Susan and Caroline showed that home dialysis could work, Dr. Scribner immediately put dozens of patients on home dialysis. People around the world started building these machines. It got cheaper. And with way more access to dialysis, they no longer needed a committee to play God.
在苏珊和卡罗琳证明家庭透析可行后，斯克里布纳医生立即让几十名患者进行了家庭透析。世界各地的人们开始建造这些机器。它变便宜了。随着透析普及程度的提高，他们不再需要一个委员会来扮演上帝了。
The God Committee story now, it's seen as a dark moment in medical history. People actually point to it as the birth of bioethics. We had to invent an entire field to deal with these questions. And we've agreed that having people vote on who makes the cut to live or to die was a bad idea.
现在，上帝委员会的故事被视为医学史上黑暗的一刻。人们实际上将其称为生物伦理学的诞生。我们必须发明整个学科来处理这些问题。而且我们一致认为，让人投票决定谁能活、谁该死是一个坏主意。
Although, the truth is, we vote on life and death decisions all the time, just from a greater distance, deciding things like who gets health insurance or where the best hospitals go-- which, in a pandemic, can make all the difference. We decide these things a lot. We just don't use the words "God Committee." It's easier that way.
尽管事实是，我们一直在投票决定生死的决定，只是从更远的距离，决定像谁能获得健康保险，或者最好的医院建在哪里——这在流行病中可能产生一切差异。我们经常决定这些事情。只是我们不用“上帝委员会”这个词。那样更容易。
Lilly Sullivan, she's one of the producers of our show. Susan Vukich, the mom in that story, died a few years back. She was 91. After her daughter Caroline died, she spent the rest of her life teaching people how to dialyze their family members at home.
莉莉·沙利文，她是我们要节目的制作人之一。苏珊·武基奇（Susan Vukich），那个故事里的母亲，几年前去世了。她享年91岁。在女儿卡罗琳去世后，她余生都在教人们如何在家为家人透析。
Act Two, Winter's Bone. So when it comes to who will love, that, of course, is not decided by a panel of experts somewhere. We each decide for ourselves who we want to be with. And one of our producers, Elna Baker, has noticed the way people are deciding on that, deciding on who makes the cut, who gets first date or becomes part of their life in a much bigger way. In New York City, where she lives, she says all that's changed lately.
第二幕，冬天的骨头。所以当谈到谁将相爱时，这当然不是由某处的专家小组决定的。我们每个人自己决定想和谁在一起。我们的制作人之一，艾尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker），注意到了人们决定这件事的方式，决定谁能入围，谁能进行第一次约会或成为他们生活中更重要的一部分，在纽约市，她居住的地方，她说一切最近都变了。
Have you heard about finding your winter? I hadn't either. Apparently, it's a thing single people in New York have been doing since COVID. Basically, over the summer and fall, people started scrambling to find someone, anyone, before winter in a second lockdown.
听说过寻找你的“冬天”吗？我也没有。显然，这是单身人士自新冠疫情以来一直在纽约做的一件事。基本上，在夏天和秋天，人们开始争先恐后地在第二次封锁的冬天到来之前找到某个人，任何人。
Back in August, completely oblivious to this phenomenon, I went on a date with a guy. We met on Hinge, the dating app. Our first date, we'd spent six feet apart in a park. For our second date, we met at an outdoor restaurant.
早在八月，完全不知道这种现象，我和一个男人约会了。我们在Hinge约会软件上认识。第一次约会，我们在公园里保持了六英尺的距离。第二次约会，我们在一家户外餐厅见面。
It was going well. We just put in our order when he said, "What do we do about Hinge?" "What do you mean?" "I mean, do I delete my profile?" "Why would you delete your profile?" "Because I met this really great girl, and I'm totally into her."
进展顺利。我们刚下单，他就说：“我们怎么处理Hinge？”“什么意思？”“我的意思是，我要删除我的资料吗？”“为什么要删除你的资料？”“因为我遇到了一个非常好的女孩，我完全迷上她了。”
I paused. "Is it-- me?" "Yes, of course." I was so confused. I'd had to pull up Hinge right before the date to remind me of his name. And he was ready to be exclusive.
我停顿了一下。“是——我吗？”“当然是。”我感到非常困惑。在约会前我不得不打开Hinge来提醒自己他的名字。而他已经准备好排他了。
I am not new to dating. This doesn't happen. Straight men in New York City rarely want relationships. The whole game is to stay single. At best, you get invited into their harem-- one of three or four people they're sleeping with. No one ever wants to eliminate the possibility of other options so quickly. But then, this kept happening. I'd go on dates, and everyone wanted to have road trip style marathon bonding sessions that lasted hours longer than usual. They wanted to see me again. They sent me flowers. They even held hands.
我不是约会新手。这种情况不会发生。纽约市的异性恋男性很少想要恋爱。整个游戏就是保持单身。充其量，你会被邀请进入他们的后宫——他们正在与之发生关系的其中三四个人之一。没有人愿意这么快就消除其他选择的可能性。但后来，这种情况不断发生。我去约会，每个人都想进行公路旅行式的马拉松联谊，持续时间比平时长几个小时。他们想再见到我。他们送我花。他们甚至牵手。
This was my first time back in the game for a while. I'd taken a break from dating for nearly a year. I'd gone through a bad breakup. I left town for a while, did some therapy, meditated. And now, back on the scene, I felt like Rip Van Winkle, waking up to a world where men suddenly wanted commitment. I went on 10 dates. Of them, nine wanted to keep seeing me.
这是我有一阵子以来第一次回到这个游戏中。我在约会方面休息了近一年。我经历了一次糟糕的分手。我离开了一阵子，做了些治疗，冥想。现在，回到现场，我感觉自己像个瑞普·凡·温克尔（Rip Van Winkle），醒来发现一个男人们突然想要承诺的世界。我去了10次约会。其中，九个人想继续见我。
By comparison, three years ago, when I was last single, I went on 35 dates. Of them, two wanted to keep seeing me. I thought, did I get hot? All those months of work on myself had really paid off. I told this all to my friend Hamza. "Did I get hot?" "Did you get hot?" He could not stop laughing. "You idiot, it's COVID."
相比之下，三年前，当我最后一次单身时，我去了35次约会。其中，两个人想继续见我。我想，我变漂亮了吗？所有那几个月的自我提升真的有了回报。我把这一切都告诉了我的朋友哈姆扎（Hamza）。“我变漂亮了吗？”“你变漂亮了吗？”他笑得停不下来。“你这个白痴，这是新冠疫情。”
That's when Hamza explained about people trying to find their winter. A friend of a friend named Christine, a single woman in her 50s, told me, in her experience, it's not subtle.
就在那时，哈姆扎解释了人们试图寻找他们“冬天”的事。一个朋友的朋友名叫克里斯汀（Christine），一位50多岁的单身女性，告诉我，以她的经验，这并不微妙。
One or two men has said to me, winter's coming, and I'm really hoping to meet someone to spend the winter with. They've said that.
一两个男人对我说过，冬天要来了，我真的很希望能遇见一个人来共度冬天。他们确实说过。
Another person I talked to, Kelsey, 22, said she recognized what was happening early because she used to see it in Chicago every winter. Before temperatures dropped to below 0 and going outside was a non-starter, people would rush to couple up. She said everyone called it cuffing season, as in handcuffs.
我谈过的另一个人，22岁的凯尔西（Kelsey），说她很早就认出了发生了什么，因为她过去在芝加哥的每个冬天都见过。在气温降至零下，出门成为不可能之前，人们会匆忙结对。她说每个人都叫它“铐子季节”（cuffing season），就像戴上手铐一样。
I was out. I was kind of seeing this guy casually, and we were out one night. And we were sitting down at the bar, kind of talking. And he was like, "Oh, by the way, we're together, right?" And I was like, "Oh my God, you don't know me. Like, no. I don't want to be exclusive with you." And by the end of the night, he had gone home with someone else.
我那时还在约会。我和一个男人随意地约会，一天晚上我们出去了。我们坐在酒吧里，一边聊天。他说：“噢，顺便说一句，我们在一起了，对吧？”我说：“天哪，你根本不了解我。就像，不。我不想和你排他。”那天晚上结束时，他已经和另一个人回家了。
So basically, it was like-- it was musical chairs. He was trying to sit down in my chair, and I said no. And he found another open chair, and he was done. And he had a great cuffing season, and I'm sure that relationship ended by the time people were going out again.
所以基本上，就像——这是抢椅子游戏。他试图坐在我的椅子上，我说不。他找到了另一把空椅子，他就完成了。他度过了一个很棒的“铐子季节”，我相信那段关系在人们再次出门时就结束了。
Kelsey says now it's COVID cuffing season, like we're living in a forever winter. We're supposed to stay in. Dating multiple people is reckless. So people are settling. She told me one roommate of hers ended up with a girl he wouldn't normally be into around Thanksgiving.
凯尔西说，现在这是“新冠铐子季节”，就像我们生活在一个永恒的冬天。我们应该呆在家里。和多个人约会是鲁莽的。所以人们在凑合。她告诉我，她的一个室友在感恩节前后最终和一个他平时不会看上的女孩在一起了。
And then, another one left and is now living in a van in Colorado with an ex-boyfriend. But she doesn't want to date, but I think she just didn't want to be anywhere near New York. That's like an extreme cuff, destination cuff.
然后，另一个人离开了，现在和前男友住在科罗拉多的一辆货车里。但她不想约会，但我认为她只是不想呆在纽约附近。这就像一种极端的“铐子”，目的地式的“铐子”。
I guess you'd think it'd be nice. After all these years of rejection, guys being into me right off the bat or being texted, "I miss you," hours after meeting. But here's the problem with what they're doing. Projecting, building up an entire fantasy based on barely knowing someone-- that's my thing. You can't take my thing.
我想你会觉得这很好。经过这么多年被拒绝，男人们第一次见面就对我有意思，或者见面几小时后就发短信“我想你”。但他们所做的事情的问题在于。投射，基于几乎不认识某人建立整个幻想——这是我的强项。你不能抢我的强项。
One time, I liked a guy so much after meeting him once that I spent a week imagining all the dates we'd go on together, including one where we got stoned and bought crayons spontaneously and colored in coloring books. By the time we went out again, I'd been on so many imaginary dates with him, my brain genuinely didn't know the difference between real life and what I'd pretended we'd done.
有一次，我见了一个男人一次就非常喜欢他，以至于我花了一周时间想象我们一起去的所有的约会，包括一个我们嗑药后自发买了蜡笔并给涂色书涂色的约会。当我们再次约会时，我已经和他进行过这么多虚构的约会，我的大脑真的无法分辨现实生活和我们假装做过的事情之间的区别。
But only one person can do that at a time. Otherwise, you're both too into it way too soon. And that's bringing delusion to delusion, and it cancels the whole thing out. Now, I feel like I'm on the other side of the equation. And watching people try to find their winter, I am watching what I used to do and how disturbing it must have been. I get why 33 out of 35 men passed on me. It's offputting. I told Kelsey, I don't like this new world of musical chairs we're living in.
但一次只能有一个人这样做。否则，你们两个都会太快沉浸其中。这会带来妄想之上的妄想，它会抵消整个事情。现在，我觉得我处于等式的另一边。看着人们试图寻找他们的冬天，我看到了我过去所做的，以及它是多么令人不安。我明白为什么35个男人中有33个拒绝了我。这让人反感。我告诉凯尔西，我不喜欢我们生活的这个新的抢椅子世界。
But the real question is, do you need a chair? I've just really-- I'd so much rather just be dancing around and not have a chair.
但真正的问题是，你需要一把椅子吗？我只是真的——我宁愿四处跳舞，不要椅子。
It's nice to sit on a chair sometimes. Sometimes, you got to sit on a chair.
有时候坐在椅子上很好。有时候，你得坐在椅子上。
Sometimes you've got to sit on a chair. But if it's an uncomfortable chair, you're going to be more miserable in the chair than not in a chair. Oh, gosh, I don't know.
有时候你得坐在椅子上。但如果这是一把不舒服的椅子，你坐在椅子上会比不坐在椅子上更痛苦。哦，天哪，我不知道。
I had this-- oh my God, I was getting out of the subway. I was getting out of the subway. And this guy approached me, and he had a mask on. And he was like, "Excuse me. Can I ask you a question?" And I thought for sure he was going to ask directions. So I said, "Yeah."
我有过这个——天哪，我正要出地铁。我正要出地铁。这个戴着口罩的人接近我。他说：“打扰一下。我能问你个问题吗？”我以为他肯定要问路。所以我说：“可以。”
And he was like, "I just bought a farm upstate, and I'm growing my own locally sourced produce. And I'm looking for a girl to get in a relationship that I can bring upstate with me. Is this something you would be interested in?"
他说：“我刚在城外买了个农场，正在种我自己本地采购的农产品。我在找一个可以建立关系的女孩，我可以带她跟我一起去城外。这事你有兴趣吗？”
Oh my gosh.
噢天哪。
And I--
而我——
That's good.
那很好。
--was like--
——就像——
You should have given him my number. I'm interested.
你应该给他我的号码。我有兴趣。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was like, what is happening to the world? Is this truly the end of days? Also because I'm used to guys using, like, "I work in finance," or, "I have financial stability." Like, using things to reel me in, but never crops. No one has ever said, "I have--"
我说，这个世界发生了什么？这真的是末日吗？而且因为我习惯了男人们使用，比如，“我在金融业工作”，或者，“我有经济稳定性”。就像，利用这些来钓我，但从来没有用过农作物。从来没有人说过，“我有——”
No.
不。
"I got some crops."
“我有一些农作物。”
Crops, but it's totally-- he's using his space. He's like, "I have fresh air and land." That's capital right now.
农作物，但这完全是——他在利用他的空间。他说，“我有新鲜空气和土地。”这现在是资本。
That is total-- it's total capital right now.
这完全是——这现在完全是资本。
I get that it's hard to be alone. But this level of desperation is a bit much. He was a step away from saying, "I have a van, two shotguns, and a can of gas. Get in. We can make it at least two weeks before the zombies catch up to us." When, really, all we're in danger of is watching Netflix alone.
我明白孤独很难。但这种程度的绝望有点过头了。他离说“我有一辆货车，两把猎枪，和一罐汽油。上车。在僵尸追上我们之前，我们至少能撑两周”只差一步。当实际上，我们面临的唯一危险是独自看Netflix。
I thought I could never be this way. But as I talked to people, I admired the single-minded practicality of some of these New Yorkers. My friend Mica is a psychologist. She says people suffer when they're isolated. People need to be touched. She went looking for a winter to preserve her mental well-being. She's not deceiving anyone. She's clear about what she's looking for-- a warm body.
我以为我永远不会这样。但当我和人们交谈时，我很钦佩其中一些纽约人那种单一目标的实用主义。我的朋友米卡（Mica）是心理学家。她说当人们被隔离时会受苦。人们需要被触摸。她为了保持心理健康而寻找冬天。她没有欺骗任何人。她清楚自己在寻找什么——一个温暖的身体。
Which doesn't sound very romantic, but I feel like that's kind of where we're at-- where I'm at-- in this moment.
这听起来不太浪漫，但我感觉这就是我们所处的——我所处的——在这一刻。
So you just want somebody for how long?
所以你只是想要某个人多久？
Until I get my vaccine.
直到我接种疫苗。
And you're totally fine with it being someone that you wouldn't normally be attracted to or want to spend time with?
你完全接受是一个你平时不会被吸引或不想共度时光的人吗？
Well, I'm having to come into that. I'm having to lower my standards.
嗯，我不得不接受。我不得不降低标准。
Would you say that you're picky?
你会说你很挑剔吗？
So I guess I used to be picky. I guess I had my list that had to be checked off, like money in the bank, good credit. Also a gentleman. Has the same vision as me, right? We're aligned, and we both want to build and community and close the racial wealth gap. You know, whatever. Be a Black power couple. I used to have on my dating profiles, I would just say, "looking for the Barack to my Michelle." That's all I would put. Someone that I--
所以我猜我过去很挑剔。我猜我有一张必须核对的清单，比如银行存款，良好的信用。还要是个绅士。有和我一样的愿景，对吧？我们志同道合，我们都想建设社区并缩小种族贫富差距。你知道，随便吧。做一对黑人权力情侣。我过去在约会资料上，我只会写，“寻找我的巴拉克（Barack）的米歇尔（Michelle）”。那就是我写的全部。某个人我——
Your standard was Barack Obama.
你的标准是巴拉克·奥巴马。
Yeah, but Barack with Michelle because Michelle's smarter than him, better than him, and he values that. And yet, she pushes him to greatness. And now, well, if you can hold a conversation, you're not overtly an asshole, and you're smart enough, yeah.
是的，但是巴拉克配米歇尔，因为米歇尔比他聪明，比他优秀，而且他很看重这一点。然而，她推动他走向伟大。而现在，好吧，如果你能进行对话，你不是一个明显的混蛋，而且你足够聪明，是的。
Even these new lower standards were not low enough. Like, she matched with a guy who had kids, which is usually a deal breaker for her and was a, quote, "filmmaker," which is another deal breaker because she feels like filmmaker is a job everyone in New York claims. But she agreed to a first date. He told her he'd bake a pie. She was expecting an entire pie. He just brought a piece. He'd eaten the rest. But she was willing to overlook it.
即使这些新的较低标准也不够低。比如，她和一个有孩子的男人匹配了，这通常是她的破坏性因素，而且还是个“电影制作人”，这是另一个破坏性因素，因为她觉得电影制作人是每个纽约人都声称从事的工作。但她同意了第一次约会。他告诉她他会烤一个派。她期待的是整个派。他只带了一片。他吃了其余的。但她愿意忽略它。
I was like, you could even tell me about your "film," quote unquote. I'll listen to that. Whatever. I'll listen to your stories about-- I don't know-- parenting during remote learning, whatever. I'm so willing.
我说，你甚至可以告诉我你的“电影”，引号里的。我会听的。随便吧。我会听你关于——我不知道——远程学习期间育儿的故事，不管是什么。我太愿意了。
But for their second date, he insisted on coming over. She kept pushing for an outdoor restaurant. When he said no, she countered with, how about coffee? Finally, he confessed he'd spent all his money on Thanksgiving dinner, and he couldn't afford it. She is still seeking a winter.
但他们的第二次约会，他坚持要过来。她一直坚持去户外餐厅。当他说不时，她用喝咖啡来反击？最后，他承认他把所有的钱都花在感恩节晚餐上了，他负担不起。她仍在寻找一个冬天。
Most people I talked to weren't as pragmatic as Mica. If anything, it's been kind of stunning, seeing people who were players before COVID suddenly questioning their life choices and wanting families, or at least, real love. Like my friend Ian, who used to be more of a Mica.
大多数我交谈过的人不像米卡那么务实。如果有的话，看到那些在新冠疫情前是玩家的人突然质疑他们的人生选择并想要家庭，或者至少是真实的爱，真是令人震惊。就像我的朋友伊恩（Ian），他过去更像是一个米卡。
Of all the people I saw searching for a winter, I was most surprised by him. When Ian is single, which he usually is, he's prolific. He would, as he put it, order men on apps to come to his apartment like you order food on Seamless. He also dates women. But the pandemic broke him-- something about being alone all those months during the first lockdown.
在我看到寻找冬天的所有人中，我最惊讶的是他。当伊恩单身时，他通常也是如此，他很多产。他会，正如他所说，在应用程序上命令男人们来他的公寓，就像你在Seamless上订餐一样。他也和女性约会。但大流行打破了他——在第一次封锁期间独自度过那几个月，有些事情改变了他。
You can't help but feel like, are we at the end of Fight Club with the world falling down around us, and you better grab onto someone's hand, or else you're going to go through it alone?
你不禁感觉，我们是否处于《搏击俱乐部》的结局，世界在我们周围崩塌，你最好抓住某人的手，否则你只能独自经历这一切？
Ian would bike through the abandoned city. It was so empty, he laid in the middle of Fifth Avenue one afternoon. It felt apocalyptic. Being alone, it changed him. When he was dating before, there were always unlimited options, always someone better.
伊恩会骑自行车穿过废弃的城市。它是如此空旷，一天下午他躺在第五大道的中间。它感觉是末日。独自一人，它改变了他。当他之前约会时，总有无限的选择，总有更好的人。
When you stop seeing everyone as an option, you can't help but start seeing people as The One, for better or worse.
当你不再把每个人都视为一种选择时，你就不禁开始把人视为“唯一”，不管好坏。
It's so dramatic, the shift.
这太戏剧化了，这种转变。
Totally. We're living in a very dramatic time, you know? When it starts to get dark at 2:00 PM, you have no choice to be like, alone? No! You know? Alone in the darkness? No, I'd rather have someone next to me, and we'll figure it out later.
完全。我们生活在一个非常戏剧化的时代，你知道吗？当下午2点开始天黑时，你别无选择，只能说，独自一人？不！你知道吗？在黑暗中孤独一人？不，我宁愿身边有某个人，我们以后再解决。
Being alone also changed Christine. She's used to being super busy. She's a successful theater person. She has two kids. Her ex and her would trade off week to week, and she'd go from having a full house to being completely alone. She lives facing the highway. And for the first time ever, there was no traffic sound.
孤独一人也改变了克里斯汀。她习惯了超级忙碌。她是一个成功的戏剧人。她有两个孩子。她和她的前任会每周轮换，她会从拥有一个完整的家庭变成彻底孤独。她住的地方对着高速公路。而且这是第一次，没有任何交通声。
And I can remember just waking up in the morning or falling asleep at night and just being in my bed and so wishing that there was somebody with me that I could hold and that I could just hug and be with in that silence. And I eventually bought myself a stuffed animal. [LAUGHS] So.
我记得早上醒来或晚上入睡时，只是躺在床上，多么希望能有某个人和我在一起，我可以抱着，我可以拥抱，并在那种沉默中与他们在一起。我最终给自己买了一个填充玩具。[笑声] 所以。
I did, too.
我也买了。
Did you?
你买了吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I bought a teddy bear. She got a unicorn and wrapped it in a baby blanket. Christine and Ian, they're not looking for someone to winter with till they get their vaccine. They want to find their person. They want love.
我买了一只泰迪熊。她买了一只独角兽，并用婴儿毯包裹着它。克里斯汀和伊恩，他们不是在寻找一个共度冬天的人，直到他们打上疫苗。他们想要找到他们的人。他们想要爱。
I think the guys I've been dating during COVID are looking for that, too. I think they genuinely believe they've found it in me. Our minds can play tricks on us when we need a break from reality, like the guy who told me he'd had a vision of the woman who he wanted to be with a month before meeting me and that when I walked up to him in the park for the first time, he recognized me because I was literally the woman of his dreams. Or the guy I dated for a week who told me I was the one and that he'd never felt a connection this powerful. These are lovely men, every one of them-- I think. I don't actually know them.
我认为我在新冠疫情期间约会的那些男人也在寻找那个。我认为他们真心相信在我的身上找到了它。当我们需要从现实中休息时，我们的思想可以戏弄我们，就像那个告诉我他在见我一个月前就有了他想共度余生的女人的愿景，当我第一次在公园走向他时，他认出了我，因为我简直就是他梦想中的女人的男人。或者那个和我约会了一周的男人，他告诉我我是那个唯一，而且他从未感受过如此强大的联系。这些人都是可爱的人，每一个都是——我想。其实我不了解他们。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, working a hotline where you help people who are in desperate need and realizing during one of the calls that you recognize the voice of one of the callers. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
艾尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，在一个你帮助处于绝望需要中的人们的热线工作，并在其中一个电话中意识到你认出了其中一个来电者的声音。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Making the Cut. In this difficult moment that we are all living through, with a pandemic and the economy the way it is, we have stories of people who need stuff and how it's decided who's going to get the stuff they need. We have arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, Reluctant Bureaucrats.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《入围》（Making the Cut）。在我们都经历的这个困难时刻，在流行病和经济现状下，我们有关于需要东西的人的故事，以及如何决定谁将得到他们需要的东西的故事。我们已经到达了我们节目的第三幕。第三幕，不情愿的官僚。
So when producer Katie Mingle started to put together a series on homelessness for the podcast 99% Invisible, she learned that if you're homeless in the Bay Area, the first thing that everyone tells you is to call this hotline, 211. That's how you get access to shelter or housing. She says you would hear about this hotline all the time from people who were experiencing homelessness. But usually, when people mentioned it, they were frustrated. They would say, "I called the number. It didn't help. I didn't get anything." And she wondered what is going on here.
所以当制作人凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）开始为播客《99%无形》（99% Invisible）制作一系列关于无家可归者的系列节目时，她了解到，如果你在湾区无家可归，每个人告诉你的第一件事就是拨打这个热线，211。这就是你获得庇护所或住房的方式。她说你总是会从经历无家可归的人那里听到这个热线。但通常，当人们提到它时，他们感到很沮丧。他们会说，“我拨打了那个号码。它没有帮助。我什么也没得到。”她想知道这里到底发生了什么。
So, over the past few months, Katie spent some time with the 211 operators as they took calls. And it turns out, whether you get access to certain kinds of help depends on exactly how homeless you're considered to be. Not everybody makes the cut. Here's Katie.
所以，在过去几个月里，凯蒂花了一些时间和211接线员在一起，当他们接听电话时。结果证明，你是否能获得某些种类的帮助取决于你被认为有多无家可归。并不是每个人都能入围。这是凯蒂。
Rashana Robinson used to answer 211 calls from a small office about halfway between Oakland and San Jose. Now, because of COVID, she takes the calls from her dining room table. If there's time between calls, she moves around the house like a hummingbird, prepping food for dinner or proofreading her daughter's homework, doing sit-ups.
拉沙娜·罗宾逊（Rashana Robinson）过去在奥克兰和圣何塞之间的一间小办公室接听211电话。现在，因为新冠疫情，她在餐桌上接听这些电话。如果在电话之间有时间，她会像蜂鸟一样在房子里走动，为晚餐准备食物或校对女儿的家庭作业，做仰卧起坐。
211 is a crisis hotline for people in need. Since COVID, they've been getting more calls than usual from people who are hungry or need help paying bills or rent. The operators can refer them to programs that might be able to offer assistance.
211是一个为需要帮助的人提供的危机热线。自新冠疫情以来，他们收到的电话比平时多，来自那些挨饿或需要帮助支付账单或租金的人。接线员可以将他们转介给可能提供援助的计划。
I talked to a homeowner the other day for almost an hour, losing her home. Talked to someone else that owns a daycare, losing it. May lose her house. Said she's losing her mind. It's devastating. It's devastating calls now. It's a lot more work.
前几天我和一位正在失去房子的房主谈了近一个小时。谈了另一个拥有托儿所的人，正在失去它。可能会失去她的房子。她说她快疯了。这太令人崩溃了。现在的电话太令人崩溃了。这是更多的工作。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
It's nonstop. Alameda County 211, how can I help you?
没完没了。阿拉米达县211，有什么能帮你的吗？
The most common reason people call, both before and after the pandemic, is homelessness. 211 can find callers a shelter bed for the night if there are beds available. Often, there's not. On a good day, they may have four or five to offer. This in a county where there are at least 8,000 people homeless on any given night. Callers seeking something more permanent, like longer term housing, there's not much of that either. But 211 can help get callers on a list. Maybe. It all depends on how they answer one question.
人们打电话的最常见原因，无论是在大流行之前还是之后，都是无家可归。如果有床位，211可以为来电者找到过夜的庇护所床位。通常，没有。在好日子里，他们可能有四五个床位提供。这还是在一个每天至少有8000人无家可归的县。寻找更永久性住房（如长期住房）的来电者，这些选择也不多。但211可以帮助将来电者列入名单。也许吧。这完全取决于他们如何回答一个问题。
And where did you sleep or stay last night?
你昨晚睡在哪儿或住在哪里？
Here, Rashana is screening a caller to see if she qualifies as literally homeless. You're literally homeless according to the county guidelines if last night, you slept in a shelter or in some place not meant for human habitation, like a tent or a car. But the caller, she's been couch surfing for the past few weeks. And last night, she tells Rashana, she slept in a motel.
在这里，拉沙娜正在筛选一名来电者，看看她是否有资格被视为真正无家可归。根据县指导方针，如果你昨晚睡在庇护所或一些非人类居住的地方，如帐篷或车里，你就是真正的无家可归。但那个来电者，过去几周一直在沙发上蹭住。昨晚，她告诉拉沙娜，她睡在汽车旅馆里。
Paid for by yourself or?
你自己付的还是？
Yes, the caller says, paid for by herself. But that's not the answer Rashana needs, so she can't forward her on to the next step to get longer term housing.
是的，来电者说，是她自己付的。但那不是拉沙娜需要的答案，所以她不能把她转到下一步以获得长期住房。
You're welcome. Bye bye.
不客气。再见。
This technicality, what does and doesn't qualify someone for housing, it's upsetting to the callers. It's upsetting to Rashana, too. She thinks about it even when she's not at work.
这个技术细节，什么算什么不算有资格住房，让来电者很心烦。这也让拉沙娜很心烦。她即使在不在工作时也会想到它。
When we're at McDonalds, me and my sister in Union City, that Motel 6, it's always all type of action over there. I see this family going in there. And I see them packing all these bags. Three or four kids, right?
当我们和我的姐妹在联合城的麦当劳时，那个6号汽车旅馆，那里总是有各种活动。我看到这个家庭进去。我看到他们带着所有这些行李。三四个孩子，对吧？
And it's like, oh, they are homeless, but they can't get help. That's fucked up. And these are the kind of people that will call me, and I say, can't help you because you stayed in a room last night. It's sad, and that's why I tell people, no, I hear you. I feel you. I know you're homeless. I'm not saying you're not. But Alameda County guidelines, these are the stipulations.
就像，哦，他们无家可归，但他们不能得到帮助。这太扯淡了。这些就是会打电话给我的人，我说，帮不了你，因为你昨晚住在房间里。这很悲哀，这就是我告诉人们的，不，我听到了。我感受到了。我知道你无家可归。我不是说你没有。但阿拉米达县指导方针，这些就是规定。
If callers meet the definition of literal homelessness, they can go into the system and be put on the list. There, they get ranked by how needy they are. The people considered most in need might get housing in two or three months. But a lot of people just languish at the bottom of the list and never get anything and end up calling 211 again. It can be a maddening cycle.
如果来电者符合真正无家可归的定义，他们可以进入系统并被列入名单。在那里，他们会根据他们有多需要来排名。被认为最需要的人可能会在两三个月内获得住房。但很多人只是在名单底部徘徊，什么也得不到，最终又打回211。这可能是一个让人抓狂的循环。
And sometimes, people get so exasperated that they yell at Rashana. She tries to listen, not take it personally, and move on to the next caller, not get too attached. But every once in a while, a caller will stick with Rashana long after she hangs up. I've heard her recall names of folks she talked to months ago. And in January of last year, she had a call she still thinks about.
有时，人们变得非常愤怒，以至于对拉沙娜大喊大叫。她试图倾听，不要往心里去，继续下一个来电者，不要太投入。但偶尔，一个来电者会在拉沙娜挂断电话后很长一段时间里留在她心里。我听她回忆几个月前谈过的人的名字。去年一月，她接到了一个她至今还在想的电话。
Good morning. Thank you for calling Alameda County 211. How can I help you?
早上好。感谢拨打阿拉米达县211。有什么能帮你的吗？
I'm homeless at Alameda County with a two-year-old son, and--
我在阿拉米达县无家可归，带着一个两岁的儿子，而且——
The caller sounded familiar to Rashana. She said she and her son were homeless and looking for help.
来电者的声音听起来对拉沙娜很熟悉。她说她和她的儿子无家可归，正在寻求帮助。
You know, like, a shelter that provides some type of housing after work, something like that, just resources. So I'm willing to move anywhere that I can get help.
你知道，像，工作后提供某种住房的庇护所，类似那样的，只是资源。所以我愿意搬到任何能得到帮助的地方。
Rashana starts asking her usual questions. Have you called 211 before? What's your phone number? What's your name?
拉沙娜开始问她通常的问题。你以前打过211吗？你的电话号码是多少？你叫什么名字？
So my first name is spelled [BLEEP], and my last name is [BLEEP].
我名字的拼写是[屏蔽]，我的姓是[屏蔽]。
Now Rashana knows why the voice sounds familiar, and you can hear her take it in. The person she was talking to was her cousin. The two hadn't seen each other in a long time. And her cousin didn't seem to realize she was talking to Rashana.
现在拉沙娜知道为什么声音听起来熟悉了，你可以听到她意识到这一点。她谈话的那个人是她的表亲。两人已经很久没见了。而她的表亲似乎没有意识到她在和拉沙娜说话。
OK. One moment.
好的。稍等。
She puts her cousin on hold and turns to her co-workers. "Fuck, this is my cousin," she tells them. When she gets back on the call, she seems not to know what to say at all, like she's lost the script completely.
她让她的表亲保持在线，转过身对同事说。“去他妈的，这是我的表亲，”她告诉他们。当她回到电话时，她似乎完全不知道该说什么，就像她完全丢掉了脚本。
OK, um--
好的，嗯——
Finally, she recovers a bit, makes her way through the screening questions.
最后，她恢复了一点，通过了筛选问题。
And do you have any friends or family you could stay with?
你有任何朋友或家人可以住在一起吗？
No.
没有。
Rashana wants to tell her cousin it's her. But they're deep in the call, and she doesn't know how to say it, so she sticks to the script. It's now nine minutes into the call, and she's finished with the screening interview.
拉沙娜想告诉她的表亲那是她。但他们已经深陷电话之中，她不知道该怎么说，所以她坚持照着脚本念。现在已经是电话进行的第九分钟，她完成了筛选面试。
OK, so you have been determined to be literally homeless. By Alameda County guidelines, you have been determined to be literally homeless.
好的，嗯，你已经被确定为真正无家可归。根据阿拉米达县指导方针，你已经被确定为真正无家可归。
Rashana tells her cousin that since she's literally homeless, she can pass her through to the next step. She might eventually get some help. And in the meantime, there's one space available in a shelter in Oakland that she could go to right away.
拉沙娜告诉她的表亲，既然她是真正无家可归，她可以把她转到下一步。她可能最终会得到一些帮助。在此期间，奥克兰有一个庇护所空出了一个空间，她可以立即去那里。
OK, so does this shelter-- how long can I stay in the shelter for?
好的，那么这个庇护所——我可以在庇护所待多久？
It just depends. It just depends. You could either, um--
这取决于。这取决于。你可以，嗯——
Finally, Rashana finds the words.
最后，拉沙娜找到了词。
This is Tiny.
我是Tiny。
Tiny is Rashana's nickname.
Tiny是拉沙娜的昵称。
This is why I sound so--
这就是为什么我听起来这么——
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
--discombobulated right now. You're messing me up right now. Oh. Yeah, I'm dead serious.
——现在有点乱。你现在让我心烦意乱。哦。是的，我是非常认真的。
That's crazy.
那太疯狂了。
I feel so bad. This is not supposed to happen to you all. [SOBS] But, um--
我感到太难过了。这不应该发生在你们身上。[抽泣] 但是，嗯——
So I guess I'll take the number to the one in Oakland, and then--
所以我猜我会拿那个在奥克兰的号码，然后——
All right.
好的。
Well, hi, Tiny. [LAUGHS]
好吧，嗨，Tiny。[笑声]
I know.
我知道。
For the next few minutes, the two cousins catch up a little, both alluding in vague ways to difficult and complicated family history.
接下来的几分钟里，两个表亲叙叙旧，都以模糊的方式暗示了困难和复杂的家庭历史。
Yes, it's been hard.
是的，一直很难。
Yeah. Man, I know. I know. I was just talking about you guys the other day. It'll get better for you. It definitely-- you're seeming still to be a go-getter, and this is the way to do it. I mean, if you got to stay through some shelters and things like that--
是的。天，我知道。我知道。我前几天还在谈论你们。这对你会好起来的。它肯定——你看起来仍然是个积极进取的人，这就是做到这一点的方法。我的意思是，如果你必须在一些庇护所里待着，类似那样的事情——
Rashana's not the only 211 operator to know someone who became homeless. Nearly all the operators who work for Alameda County 211 are women of color. And homelessness is disproportionately affecting Black and Brown people in the Bay Area. One operator named Gwen told me she'd been homeless herself for about five years, not that long ago. At the end of the call, Rashana transfers her cousin to the place where she can get on the list for help with housing.
拉沙娜不是唯一一个认识无家可归的人的211接线员。几乎所有为阿拉米达县211工作的接线员都是有色人种女性。而且无家可归在湾区对黑人和棕色人种的影响不成比例。一个名叫格温（Gwen）的接线员告诉我，她自己不久前还无家可归了五年。在电话结束时，拉沙娜把她的表亲转到了可以列入住房援助名单的地方。
I'm going to connect you. I got you connected, OK?
我把你接过去。我已经把你接通了，好吗？
OK. Did you take my number down?
好的。你记下我的号码了吗？
Yeah, I got your number down. I'm going to text you mine, OK?
是的，我记下你的号码了。我会把我的号码发短信给你，好吗？
OK.
好的。
OK, I love you.
好的，我爱你。
I love you, too.
我也爱你。
All right.
好的。
Looking back on that call, Rashana recognizes that some of her hesitancy around telling her cousin it was her had to do with her own doubts around what she was ready to offer.
回顾那个电话，拉沙娜意识到她在告诉表亲是她时的某些犹豫与她对自己准备提供什么感到怀疑有关。
And I didn't really want to fully, at that point, extend my hand as in a place to stay because I didn't feel like I was in the position to do that. I just didn't want to be faced with that because, in my heart, I wouldn't have had the heart to be like, no, you can't come here.
而且我当时真的不想完全伸出援手作为一个住处，因为我觉得我不处于那个位置。我只是不想面对那个，因为在心里，我没有心说，不，你不能来这里。
Rashana had been in this situation before-- not with this cousin, but with another family member. And she knew once you invite someone in, you have to be willing to let them stay until they find another situation. After that 211 call with Rashana, it ended up being about six months before her cousin was able to get herself back into her own place.
拉沙娜以前处于过这种情况——不是这个表亲，而是另一个家庭成员。她知道一旦你邀请某人进来，你就必须愿意让他们住到找到另一个住处。在那次与拉沙娜的211电话后，大约过了六个月，她的表亲才得以回到自己的住所。
When these operators actually do have something tangible to offer their callers, they jump at the chance. At the end of one of her workdays, Rashana answers the phone for a caller who needs a shelter bed tonight. Luckily, she's just gotten word that five beds have opened up in a shelter in Oakland. So she has something to offer. Only, there's a problem. The client is across town at a kidney dialysis center, and he needs to be at the shelter by 6:00 PM. It's currently around 10 minutes after 5:00.
当这些接线员真的有实质性的东西提供给来电者时，他们会抓住机会。在她的工作日结束时，拉沙娜接听了一个今晚需要庇护所床位的来电者的电话。幸运的是，她刚得到消息说奥克兰的一个庇护所空出了五个床位。所以她有东西可以提供。只是，有一个问题。客户在城对面的肾透析中心，他需要在下午6点前赶到庇护所。现在大约是5点10分左右。
So you need to get over to EOCP by 6:00 PM. Is there anyone there? No, calm down. Calm down. It's OK. Is there anyone there that would be willing to give you a ride? No, no, no, 6:00. Yeah, 6:00 tonight.
所以你需要在下午6点前赶到EOCP。那里有人吗？不，冷静点。冷静点。没事。那里有人愿意载你一程吗？不，不，不，6点。是的，今晚6点。
This caller-- his name is James Reese-- was panicking. If he couldn't get into the shelter, he imagined he'd have to sleep outside that night.
这个来电者——他的名字是詹姆斯·里斯（James Reese）——在惊慌。如果他不能进入庇护所，他想象他今晚必须睡在外面。
No one here. There's no one here to help me.
这没人。这没人帮我。
Um, let me place you on a quick hold to see what I can do about transportation. OK? Let me place--
嗯，让我把你快速转接，看看我能为交通做些什么。好吗？让我把——
The 211 operators don't really have a budget to help callers with transportation. But there is this very small fund, Rashana tells me, for Lyft rides, although she doesn't think this situation meets the criteria to use the funding.
211接线员其实没有预算帮助来电者解决交通问题。但拉沙娜告诉我，有一个非常小的Lyft乘车基金，尽管她认为这种情况不符合使用该资金的标准。
You don't have a way to even take the bus home, Mr. Reese?
里斯先生，你连乘公交车回家的钱都没有吗？
No. I really-- you guys are trying to help me, and I appreciate you so much.
不。我真的——你们在试图帮助我，我非常感激你们。
Rashana puts Mr. Reese back on hold and opens the app for Lyft on her computer. Her brow is furrowed. Her cursor is hovering over the Request Ride button. She says to me, this is where the humanity comes into it. Most of the day, it's do you fit the criteria or not. Call the number, read the script, go through the protocols. But now, she's going to make her own decision.
拉沙娜让里斯先生再次保持在线，并在她的电脑上打开了Lyft应用程序。她眉头紧锁。她的光标悬停在“请求乘车”按钮上。她对我说，这就是人性介入的地方。大多数时候，这取决于你是否符合标准。拨打号码，阅读脚本，经过协议。但现在，她要做出自己的决定。
(WHISPERING) I'm going to do it. OK, um, Mr. Reese, I'm going to get you a Lyft ride.
（低声说）我要做了。好的，嗯，里斯先生，我要为你叫一辆Lyft车。
It's rare having a problem she can solve, even if it means bending the rules a bit. Mr. Reese has 40 minutes to get to the shelter, but it's a 30 minute ride with traffic.
有一个她能解决的问题是很少见的，即使这意味着稍微变通一下规则。里斯先生有40分钟赶到庇护所，但车程在交通拥堵时需要30分钟。
Oh, you'll be getting picked up in 3 minutes by a Ricardo. He's driving a white Honda Accord.
哦，你会由一位叫里卡多（Ricardo）的司机在3分钟内接走。他开的是一辆白色本田雅阁。
OK.
好的。
OK?
好的？
I'm going to get-- I'll be sitting in the lobby. Thank you.
我要去——我会坐在大厅里。谢谢。
Have a good night.
晚安。
Bye bye.
再见。
Rashana hangs up the phone, but on her computer screen, we can see that Ricardo the driver has pulled up to the address Mr. Reese gave. He's just sitting there. Why is Ricardo just sitting there if Mr. Reese is in his car?
拉沙娜挂断了电话，但在她的电脑屏幕上，我们可以看到司机里卡多已经开到了里斯先生提供的地址。他就在那儿坐着。如果里斯先生在他的车里，为什么里卡多就在那儿坐着？
He's waiting. He's going to leave.
他在等。他要走了。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Mr. Reese. He's there.
嗨，里斯先生。他在那儿。
OK. Hey, I'm coming out. I'm coming out right here.
好的。嘿，我出来了。我正从这儿出来。
OK, you may want to hurry.
好的，你可能得快点。
OK, OK. Here I go. Thank you.
好的，好的。我来了。谢谢。
Mr. Reese, he's now left, and the ride was canceled.
里斯先生，他现在离开了，而且乘车被取消了。
Huh? No, no, I'm right here!
哈？不，不，我就在这儿！
Hold on one second, Mr. Reese.
里斯先生，等一下。
She puts him back on hold. I'm not sure if she's going to get him another Lyft or if that was his one chance. It's 5:30. He'd already be late, but maybe not too late. Rashana tries again.
她让他再次保持在线。我不确定她是否会再给他叫一辆Lyft，或者那是否是他唯一的机会。现在是5点半。他已经会迟到了，但也许不会太迟。拉沙娜再次尝试。
Robel in a green Toyota Prius will be picking you up in six minutes.
开绿色丰田普锐斯的罗贝尔（Robel）将在6分钟内接你。
Pardon me? Oh, gosh. Hello?
你说什么？哦，天哪。喂？
I'm still here, Mr. Reese.
我还在，里斯先生。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
I have to stay on with you until you get in that car.
我必须一直和你保持通话，直到你上车。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Five more minutes. He's not going to make it. He'll still be late.
还有五分钟。他来不及了。他仍然会迟到。
Oh, come on, car.
哦，来吧，车子。
Oh, he's there. He's waiting for you. Green Toyota Prius.
哦，他在那儿。他在等你。绿色丰田普锐斯。
Oh, man. I am standing right here--
哦，天哪。我就站在这儿——
OK, Mr. Reese, you may have to walk around and look for a green Toyota Prius. Come on, let's look for the vehicle.
好的，里斯先生，你可能得走动一下，找找那辆绿色丰田普锐斯。来吧，让我们找找那辆车。
OK.
好的。
Yes, so you can get in there.
是的，这样你就能进去了。
We can see the driver's blue hovering on the screen, circling the block. But they don't seem to be finding each other.
我们可以看到屏幕上代表司机的蓝色光标在环绕街区。但他们似乎没找到对方。
OK, let me try to call the driver. Hold on one second. There are four more agonizing minutes of back and forth on a conference call between Rashana, Mr. Reese, and Robel, the Lyft driver. Mr. Reese is describing landmarks, describing himself. Finally, they find each other.
好的，让我试着给司机打电话。等一下。在拉沙娜、里斯先生和Lyft司机罗贝尔之间的电话会议中，又有四分钟令人揪心的往返沟通。里斯先生在描述地标，在描述自己。最后，他们找到了对方。
I'm getting in the car.
我要上车了。
You're in the car?
你上车了吗？
Thank you. I'm in the car.
谢谢。我上车了。
Perfect. You're going to be a few minutes late, but just calmly explain that you were told to come.
完美。你会迟到几分钟，但只要冷静地解释你被告知要来。
He thanks her. She hangs up.
他谢谢她。她挂了电话。
Good. He's on his way.
很好。他在路上了。
Whoa.
哇。
Yeah. Good, that's a good thing. I guess that's what keeps you going, even if it's one person that gets a place inside tonight. It's like-- [SNIFFS].
是的。很好，那是件好事。我猜这就是让你坚持下去的东西，即使今晚只有一个人能得到一个住处。就像——[吸鼻子]。
Getting Mr. Reese to that shelter was one real thing before the day's end, one person who Rashana knew for sure wouldn't sleep outside that night. It doesn't always go like that.
在一天结束前让里斯先生赶到那个庇护所是一件真实的事情，一个人拉沙娜确信今晚不会睡在外面。事情并不总会那样发展。
I hadn't thought about it that much before this, but bureaucracies aren't just frustrating for the people trying to navigate them. They're frustrating for the people working inside of them, too. No one really has any agency, no power to make a decision that could really help someone. All the operators told me the best calls are like this one, when they feel like they actually have something to offer. But calls like this are rare. Mostly, Rashana has to be the voice telling people they're not going to get what they need-- not right away and maybe not ever.
在此之前我并没有过多地考虑过这个问题，但官僚机构不仅对试图驾驭它们的人来说很令人沮丧。对在其中工作的人来说也同样令人沮丧。没有人真正有任何代理权，没有权力做出真正能帮助某人的决定。所有的接线员都告诉我最好的电话是像这样的一次，当他们感觉自己真的有东西可以提供时。但这样的电话很少见。大多时候，拉沙娜必须是那个告诉人们他们得不到他们需要的东西的声音——不是马上，也许永远得不到。
Katie Mingle, she's normally a producer for the 99% Invisible podcast, though she just released an entire series on homelessness in the Bay Area. It's called According to Need. It has big fans on our staff. You can check it out on the 99% Invisible podcast feed wherever you get your podcasts.
凯蒂·明格，她通常是播客《99%无形》的制作人，尽管她刚发布了一个关于湾区无家可归者的完整系列节目。它叫《根据需要》（According to Need）。它在我们员工中有很多忠实粉丝。你可以在《99%无形》播客源上收听它，无论你在哪里获取播客。
[MUSIC - "I HOPE I GET IT" BY A CHORUS LINE ENSEMBLE]
[音乐 - A CHORUS LINE合唱团的《我希望能入选》（I Hope I Get It）]
Well, our program was produced today by Lina Misitzis. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva De Kornfeld, Hillary Elkins, Noor Gill, Damian Grave, Chana Joffe-Walt, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
好吧，我们的节目今天由莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）制作。今天制作节目的工作人员包括Bim Adewunmi、艾尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、阿维娃·德·科恩菲尔德（Aviva De Kornfeld）、希拉里·埃尔金斯（Hillary Elkins）、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、达米安·格雷夫（Damian Grave）、查纳·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·赖曼（Nadia Reiman）、阿里·萨珀斯坦（Ari Saperstein）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emmanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Lisa Pollak, Whitney Henry-Lester, Abby Madan, Alison DeJung, Ian Fidance, Andrew Collins, Kelsey Padgett, and Simon Adler and Molly Webster at Radiolab.
我们的管理编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emmanuele Berry）。今天特别感谢丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、惠特尼·亨利-莱斯特（Whitney Henry-Lester）、艾比·马丹（Abby Madan）、艾莉森·德荣（Alison DeJung）、伊恩·菲丹斯（Ian Fidance）、安德鲁·柯林斯（Andrew Collins）、凯尔西·帕吉特（Kelsey Padgett），以及Radiolab的西蒙·阿德勒（Simon Adler）和莫莉·韦伯斯特（Molly Webster）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He always notices the little things. He started rolling the bottom of my pants in a new way. He is not into it.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费流式传输我们超过700集的档案。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心，传递给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他总是注意到小事。他开始用一种新的方式卷起我裤子的底部。他不喜欢。
That's like an extreme cuff.
那就像一种极端的“铐子”。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "I HOPE I GET IT" BY A CHORUS LINE ENSEMBLE]
[音乐 - A CHORUS LINE合唱团的《我希望能入选》（I Hope I Get It）]